nesco review a spider was my impression
so I'm like black Batman yo the amazing
spider-man dos the Spanish version of
Peter Parker picked orc parkour the
Heisei Parker in Spanish what do you
know if your your way this is one of the
most anticipated movies of the year now
with 15 movie clips 14 trailers and 13
alternate vinyl trailers doesn't deliver
on all the hype yeah I guess the movie
does have some great moments what you
expect to be great is great the action
and visual effects is top-notch
I would [ __ ] it that's all it's an IMAX
3d IMAX and it looks so real the whole
time it was like how did they get some
of those shots it was really impressive
if you swore some people had died while
they were making this movie they
probably did they find covered up
[ __ ] America under damn conspiracies
but yeah honestly it's like the best
spider-man action we've ever seen no
spider-man 2 is better not the amazing
spider-man spider-man 2 it's not getting
confused the acting is extremely
top-notch first off Andrew Garfield as
Petra Parker this dude is the [ __ ] I
would smell this guy [ __ ] I personally
think he's more compelling to watch than
Tobey Maguire MJ that's my juggling
Maguire impression Mary Jane I do Jerry
Garfield he's super funny not the cat
Andrew Garfield he's super funny super
sarcastic really witty but damn does he
get emotional he had me almost crying a
couple times almost not a little [ __ ]
Emma Stone is gwen stacy doing her emma
stone thing that she does all of her
scenes are with Garfield the cat and the
chemistry between them is fantastic
it's no wonder why they're banging in
real life that'll be so hot if they
released a porno of those two minion I
would watch that [ __ ] over and over
again would Sally and Jerry probably
just year ever watch porn with a girl
it's always like the judges of warranty
like it's really annoying what did it
sound like that where they movie like
that you just want a buddy you can jerk
off with anyway we're getting on top of
here but the movie is flawed
like there's a lot going on it's not
like annoying compact like spider-man 3
which oh god that was annoying you shut
up [ __ ] you Sally but you got a lecture
1
kill spider-man you got hairy awkward
and wanting to save his own life you got
Peter wanting to learn the truth about
his father
you got Peter in a maze conference call
freight Peter and Gwen whether wondering
whether or not they should be together
there's just so much going on in this
film I felt like sometimes it was so
compact that the pacing and tone was
just a little bit off like a lot of this
movie was filled with moments that were
good sometimes really good but I felt it
was always at the tipping point of being
great this movie had a real push and
pull' lot about it it would be like oh
this is really good [ __ ] then huh you're
now you're losing me but I'm back in but
now I'm gone but I'm back but overall it
felt like oh we got to hurry this [ __ ]
up because we got a lot of cover at the
same time these flaws they kind of work
because it's supposed to capture that
age that Peter Parker is at where life
is chaotic and stuff so it's sort of
makes sense because at least
everything's affecting him and he's
getting all emotional about it he cries
a lot in this film he's a good crier
like when he cries he is cool when he
cries he makes you wanna cry so you
could look just as badass as Hamill as a
standalone film is it good yes it's good
but that's not the masterpiece people
were hoping to be of high expectations
prepare for them to be a little bit
undelivered but the performances are yes
they're great Jamie Foxx as electro
turning a black guy blue hmm smart move
I didn't fully buy the cartoonish
portrayal of max it was a little bit too
over-the-top it was like watching Roger
Rabbit but I liked it more when he
became Elektra but then that's where
another flaw of this poem is because the
first 30 minutes they put so much focus
on Max and electro and then he's kind of
just gone for a lot of the film then
they bring him back for the cool finale
now is it kind of a letdown it's cuz
he's black that's why they did that
KFC salad but yeah that epic fight scene
would have been more felt if we gave
more of a [ __ ] about Max Jamie hi I
[ __ ] loved him as Harry Osborn he's
super compelling very troubled that's my
trouble the expression I point to my
breasts in comparison to James Franco
they're very different but who do I
prefer James D Han no wrong in Dane
Leone and the trailer reveals the twist
in the film where he does become Green
Goblin love the trailers they really
kept stuff to the imagination but I
gotta admit his transition into becoming
the Green Goblin was not that big of a
payoff it could have been a lot cooler
they could have saved it for the third
movie
a good score in a film but the music in
this was a little bit over the top they
have this like triumph bit American
music that just always distracted me and
seem cheesy and I just didn't quite fit
for the tone of this film look I know it
sounds like I'm bagging on the film a
lot but truthfully I really enjoyed it
quite a lot but it's a pretty good film
my only problem was I just wasn't as
moved by it as I want it to be it's the
kind of movie that I think will grow on
me over time like I feel like when I'm
currently focused on now I won't be as
focused on later and I'll just be
absorbed by everything I loved about it
so yes let me clarify I love the action
I love the performances I love the
visual effects I love the romance I
don't look at me like you're bored there
time for a movie there is a lot of good
incredible shitman in it yeah sure it's
good it's good just doesn't quite live
up to what people want it to be let me
get straight to the point here oh no I
gotta say the amazing spider-man 2 got
it right for the most part all right
guys thanks checking out my review for
the amazing spider-man 2 why don't you
go head scroll that comment box below
and tell us would you watch a porno if
it started Andrew Garfield and Emma
Stone that is the question and if you
want to see more episodes straight to
the point I don't want to get a heads-up
out there we're doing a spoiler review
of the amazing spider-man 2 Jerry and
this girl named Lexi and Lexi's new to
the channel she's Italian
I love Italians Italians are the best
they make great pizza breadsticks
chicken parmesan pasta and they
validated Olive Garden and last but not
least if you want to get updated every
time one of my reviews or videos is out
go ahead and click on this button my my
dick to subscribe that's right
the dick let me take some time at this
little Peter every time he shoots out
one of his webs he goes slinging around
the room hanging on by his penis it's an
uncomfortable experience thank you let
me take some that this little Peter
every time you shoot that one of his
webs
he creates babies take three let me say
something about this little Peter the
public loves him with the police think
he's a menace come on below and tell me
which dick joke you thought was the best